like  men's life generally average men is a  very lonely existence  whereas women women don't get okay so an  average an average woman  can walk out of her house looking  regular  in a tracksuit or like with a bonnet on  or whatever and still get attention from  them  [Applause]  and the average man walking at his house  does not get any attention his dm's are  dry yeah he doesn't get any attention  sounds like a rough life i'll be easy  out there though i'm just saying that  like the average guy doesn't get the  same thing that an average woman would  get that's what andrew tate says that  like women don't know real loneliness  because there's always someone that'll  date a girl like even like the girls on  500 pound life have like boyfriends but